n dat day 11 today was the rough cut
screening of everyone's projects I think
that this class really is more about
pre-production than everything and I
think that's the thing that gets a
little overlooked by most people at
least who are trying to come from a
technical side that they need production
as when the camera comes on but you just
show up and sit down and do your
interview and you leave and they
overlook how much work it takes leading
up to that point and of course coming
afterwards then what I was most pleased
about today with that people scripts in
these videos had really come a long way
it's really funny because people and I
know I said this before but it's easy to
look at something that someone else has
made and point out all the flaws and
it's so hard to be able to learn from
that and and implement that in your own
work some of them are excellent critique
errs and then you see or excellent
critics and you see their work and
they're making the same mistakes at
their pointing out with other people
that's partially because it's very hard
to execute some of these things well and
it's also hard to see that you're not
doing it the other thing is when I first
started planning this class I was so
obsessed with every day being perfect
and I would spend hours and hours just
on the presentation I think the
aesthetic of the presentation was really
important to me how I would say things
how it laid them out that there'd be
sort of this branding in the class and
today I feel like things started chained
together at the last minute and it was
okay it turned out fine for the rough
cut editing we had spent just I guess
it's been months now trying to get this
video annotation software to work we
were emailing back and forth with the
developers which hours or the class
started at the last minute we were
creating google spreadsheets to use
those instead and it worked out fine
doing what's best for the class and not
using technologies that exist just for
the sake of using them is something I'm
learning to do I caught myself in the
editing spreadsheets I would say you
know try this if you have time and I
would almost feel bad bringing stuff
of what they should reshoot but then I
think like this is part of the
experience this is why we gave them to
hold extra days to to do reshoots is to
reshoot things and I shouldn't feel bad
about making them be more work but it's
a fine line that I'm trying to toe
really well because I do sympathize with
the demands of being a student here so
I'm not really sure if I'm doing that
super well and I'm basically relying on
their individual feedback to get a sense
of that